so now if you if you gave 10 bucks uh
maybe your account can be freezed by
your own bank you know
you do that in a communist country in a
communist country not supposed to happen
in canada but justin trudeau is doing
that right now you don't need to use
these kind of powers to be able to to
solve the the situation to resolve the
situation in uh in enter in ottawa right
now
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the founder and leader of the people's
party of canada maxine bernier
maximum old friend welcome back to the
reuben report
thank you very much very pleased to be
with you
i wish we were talking under better
circumstances but unfortunately the man
who is your prime minister up there in
canada has exercised these emergency
powers we're going to get into all of
that and you've really been at the
forefront of fighting for freedom from a
canadian perspective for many many years
i thought i could just throw to one
video real quick up top because i've had
you on the show a couple times over the
years first time was about three years
ago this month and we did an event
together about two and a half years ago
in canada and antifa showed up and a
bunch of the sort of hysterical lefties
who have seemingly taken over your
government showed up and i think a bunch
of people will remember this
[Music]
yes
[Music]
all right so the reason i started with
that is because you have been talking
about freedom and liberty and choice and
individual rights in canada for many
years that right there that woman
yelling you know your nazis etc etc
yelling it to a woman whose husband who
is next to her actually fought against
nazis in world war ii um that has been
much of the response and it seemingly
has leaked into your government now so i
thought that would be a good place to
start us off
yeah absolutely you're right you know
the world culture it's all in otawa
right now in parliament and as you know
justin trudeau
said to the protesters that are in
ottawa and i was there the last two
weekends that they are racist and
xenophobe and he tried to discredit the
people that are participating in that
protest i call that a rally you know
because i was there people were smiling
that was fun dancing on this in the
street
and
it was fun because
these people that were there understand
that the end of all these mandates is
happening and right now you know in
certain provinces in canada like
saskatchewan alberta quebec they will
lift all their mandates this month so
it's only the federal government that is
saying no no no we need to put more
restriction on your freedoms with that
emergencies act that trudeau used uh
this uh this week
how closely are you associated with the
truckers it's a little hard to tell how
these groups are all associated who was
coordinating all of this stuff
but clearly in two weeks they made a lot
of
forward movement so as you just said
some of the premiere started saying hey
we're gonna scale this stuff back
trudeau then had a moment to say okay
let's do it let's let's relax on this
stuff and instead he put his foot on the
gas
hey double down it double down on
restrictions and you know there's no
emergency in canada right now and you
know if you use that emergencies act you
must show the the
traditional is very high and you must
show that we are in a war in canada
there's insurrection in canada our
democracy is in danger that's not the
case and a lot of experts legal expert
said this week that there's no
justification for justin trudeau to use
that emergency act and actually the the
premier of quebec the premier of alberta
the premier of saskatchewan said to
trudeau we don't want you to use these
powers we don't need that act and we
don't want that in our province but
trudeau didn't listen and he went and he
used it and now you know
in ottawa uh the police will uh act and
i don't know what can happen but that
protest was very peaceful uh and people
are happy to be there and we'll see but
trudeau has one solution that he can use
and that would be very very effective
it's uh to end the mandate at the
federal level actually as you know i
cannot travel in my own country by plane
because i'm not double that that's
unconstitutional and illegal and that's
why i'm suing right now the federal
government because of that but trudeau
can end that tomorrow there's no
scientific reason for that there's no
justification for that but no he's
doubling down with that
legislation
so i get that guys like you and i maybe
are in a little bubble we love freedom
we're we're around an awful lot of
people who like to live freely i know
it's a very radical idea but do you have
a sense of who is really supporting
trudeau i i don't see many people
actually supporting him even just
cursorily looking online i don't see a
lot of support for justin trudeau i
don't see a lot of poor support for
exercising these emergency powers i see
an awful lot of pushback but i don't see
the people that are like yes he is doing
it right and these people are racists
and you know they should have their
heads crushed by the government
no the way that is managing that crisis
uh he didn't have a lot of support from
the population and actually we are
growing our support we the people's
party you know we created that party in
2018 our first election was in 2019 we
had 1.6 percent of the vote our second
election last september 5 of the vote
and now the last poll this week we're
supposed to be around 10
so we are growing our support is growing
but for trudeau the way that he managed
that crisis it's for him it's a power
grab that's it and i believe that more
and more canadians understand that and
i don't if we have an election tomorrow
it will it won't be good for justin to
do
what do you think his end game here is i
mean he's obviously scared a lot of
people and i want to talk to you about
what your deputy prime minister said
obviously christia freeland who had you
know gave this just unbelievably awful
speech and that they're going to freeze
bank accounts and all that but but
before we get to that what do you think
his real end game is this purely i'm
going to scare the hell out of these
people enough of them will disappear and
my reign of power will just continue is
that is that is it as simple as that it
may be something like that but
you know it's very difficult to
understand what um
what he wants to do uh actually what we
know is for being sure that they think
that
a bunch of violent people are
in a tower right now and that's not true
and more and more people understand that
it's not true and actually as you know
the bridge the ambassador bridge we had
a protest over there and the police was
able to solve that peacefully and now
the bridge is open so without having
emergencies uh act in force so i don't
know trudeau
like he said during the last electoral
campaign
he is very uh good at devising the
population good canadians and bad
canadians and for him the good one at
the one that are listening to him and
having the two shots or three shots and
all these mandates and canadians that
want to have more main dates and that
must stop but no he's doubling down on
that and it's worth mentioning that
trudeau was re-elected not too long ago
with less than a third of the popular
vote that's just an important little
piece to say so when the deputy prime
minister got up there freeland and said
this thing about how they will freeze
bank accounts for people who donate to
the truckers that they're going to make
sure that they cannot crowdfund that
they are going to figure out ways to
regulate uh cryptocurrency and a series
of other things first off i don't know
that they can do all that stuff i mean
regulating crypto the whole point of
crypto is so that you can't regulate it
but putting that aside i can imagine
that that the average person that is out
there with you in ottawa the average
truck driver who these are not wealthy
people for the most part they're they're
just you know
decent working-class people they get
scared they get scared and then suddenly
they don't want to donate they don't
want to be photographed out there and
and maybe that threat does enough to end
this thing
yeah but you know it's sad it's very sad
that in canada
you use that kind of power to uh you
know these people that are giving to the
truckers are not terrorists they're not
participating in a violent uh you know
actions or something like that they're
giving money to the truckers because
they believe in freedom and they want to
regain their freedoms that's it so now
if you if you gave 10 bucks
maybe your account can be freezed by
your own bank you know
you do that in a communist country in a
communist country not supposed to happen
in canada but justin trudeau is doing
that right now you don't need to use
these kind of powers to be able to to
solve the the situation to resolve the
situation in uh in enter in ottawa right
now
do you think i mean at the end of the
day i know he's head of the liberal
party and we've often talked about
classical liberalism together but this
man is no liberal in any in any real
sense of the word uh he's either a
socialist or a communist or or a fascist
i would argue at this point
what do you think really drives him what
do you think is really driving him at
this point because he did not have to do
this there was a moment a few days ago
where some of the premiers were saying
we're going to scale back and clearly
you guys were going to hear the message
it was obvious but he didn't as i said
so what do you think he really is trying
to accomplish
but i believe that
you know
power grab i believe that he enjoyed the
fact that he can have all these power
and
putting more restriction on our rights i
believe that his do is acting like a
communist dictator right now and i
believe that he's enjoying that because
there's no reason
to use that and to do that to stop that
they were very successful to stop the
protests at the ambassador bridge
peacefully so you can do that and the
answer is and all these mandate and
provincial governments in canada are
listening to the truckers and ending all
these mandate except the federal
government it's you know there's no
logic in all that and i hope because the
parliament will have to vote on that
legislation uh next week and i hope it
won't pass if it doesn't pass it would
be the end if the if that legislation
that emergency act is in force todo will
have another 30 days to use all these
power if not that would be the end and i
hope we still have political parties in
ottawa in parliament that believe in
freedom and believe in our country and i
hope that they're gonna say no to justin
trudeau next week
are you hopeful that the conservative
party you guys have a conservative party
that is not really conservative it's
sort of it's sort of liberal but that's
for a whole other conversation but are
you confident that perhaps you guys and
and the more liberty-minded people can
guide them properly it does seem maybe
at some level that this candace bergen
who's now heading the party is at least
at least pretending to be a little more
uh for freedom yes she's pretending but
we'll see actually as you know trudeau
doesn't have the majority in canada and
parliament and he will
he will need another party to pass that
and the ndp the strong leftist said that
they will vote with trudeau so that may
pass in parliament and you still have
just senate in canada and maybe the
senate will be able to stop that
but i don't count on the conservative
party anymore like you said they're
intellectually morally corrupt they're
not conservative they're doing politics
based on survey they don't have any
conviction they were not there the last
two years i was alone fighting for
freedom doing some rallies being out
there speaking with canadians but the
conservative they agreed with everything
that trudeau did for the last two years
i know you don't want extra credit for
this because i i know you as a friend
but you actually got arrested but about
a year ago uh the video you took the
video as it was happening it was pretty
extraordinary um
you know we'll we'll lay it in right
here so people can see
after you and sir yes clark with the
rcmp yeah i can get you stuff by the
vehicle i'm going to place you in a rest
right now
right now you're under arrest under the
provincial health orders okay so if you
can just put your hands behind your back
face towards the vehicle
okay give me one hand here i'll guess
you should stay in the vehicle okay
the other hand
do you have any weapons or anything on
you sir
weapon no no weapon i'm
sorry anything on you that's gonna hurt
me or anything like that no no anything
will hurt you only my words only my
philosophy only what i believe in okay
all right come on over this way i'll
explain a few things
that moment for you
and and what you said was just so
perfect so beautiful your words are what
you have that's what they fear in
essence
this can't be fun this can't be fun what
you're going through there yeah i didn't
expect that you know after a rallying
apart being arrested
and put in jail for 12 hours for a
non-crime
in canada that happened last summer and
like i said in my speeches i'm ready to
go back to jail to fight for our
freedoms and i will always fight for
what is good for this country
maxine what can people do to help you
know obviously we're trying to amplify
the message here people are trying to
help with crowdfunding whatever they can
do and it has nothing to do with
supporting racists or bigots or
homophobes or transphobes or any of the
other nonsense which is exactly why i
played that video up top because that's
what they were yelling about us three
years ago what else can we do to help
well first of all they can follow me on
twitter maxine bernier they can also go
on our website people's party of
canada.ca they can donate they can help
us this new political party is growing
step by step and i believe that the
future will be better for for us for
canadians if we have more support but
our support is growing so they can go
and read our platform they're gonna see
that we have a platform that is based on
based on four principle individual
freedom personal responsibility respect
and fairness thank you for giving me
that opportunity to speak to you and
with your viewers
maxime i know you will always fight for
canada but i want you to know that i've
got an extra guest room here if you ever
consider political asylum florida ain't
bad but i know i know you wouldn't do it
because i know you're going to fight for
your country i appreciate that thank you
dave
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
international issues instead of non-stop
yelling check out our international
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell